♪ (music) ♪
(clapping)
Hello.
My name is Alex,
and I'm here to tell you
about Eager Execution,
which I think you've heard
in the last two talks now.
But I'm here to tell you
what it's actually about.
This new, imperative,
object-oriented,
pythonic way of using TensorFlow,
that we're introducing to you today
as part of TensorFlow core.
So, you know because you're here,
or because you're watching the livestream,
I hope, that TensorFlow has been
this graph execution engine
for machine learning,
that lets you run graphs
at like high scale
and all sorts of other nice things.
But has it?
And why did we choose to go
with graphs in the first place?
Since now I'm going to tell you
about Eager Execution,
where we move beyond
what we can achieve with graphs,
I think it's a good idea to recap
why we bothered.
And a really good reason
why you want
to have your computation represented
as a platform-independent graph
is that once you have that,
it's very easy to differentiate the graph.
And I went to grad school
before auto diff was standard
in machine learning toolkits
and I do not wish that on any one.
Like, it's... life is much
better now trust me
Also, if you have a platform-independent,
abstract representation
of your computation,
you can just go and deploy it
to pretty much anything you want.
You can run it on the TPU.
You can run it on the GPU.
You can put it on a phone;
you can put it on a Raspberry Pi.
There are like all sorts of cool
deployment scenarios
you're going to hear about today.
And it's really valuable to have this kind
of platform-independent view.
Also, compilers work with data flow
graphs internally,
and they know how to do
all sorts of nice optimizations
that rely on having a global view
of your computation,
like constant folding, common
subexpression elimination,
like data laying and things like that.
And a lot of these optimizations
are really deep learning specific.
We can choose how to properly
lay out your channels and your height,
and width and stuff.
So, your convolutions are faster.
And finally, a key reason that's very
important to us at Google,
and I hope important to you as well
is that once you have
a platform-independent
representation of your computation,
you can just deploy it, and distribute it
across hundreds of machines
or a TPU-pod, like they showed earlier.
And this is a very seamless process.
So, since graphs are so good,
what made us think that now it's a good
idea to move beyond them
and let you do eager execution?
Good place to start
is that you don't actually
have to give up
automatic differentiation.
I'm sure like you're familiar with like
other frameworks, like Pythons
Autograph that let...
sorry Autograd,
that let you differentiate
dynamic code and...
You don't need to have an a priori
of your computation differentiated.
You can just build up a trace as you go,
and then walk back the trace
to compute gradients.
Also, if you don't stop
to build a platform...
like this computational graph,
you can iterate a lot more quickly.
You can play with your model
as you build it.
You can inspect it.
You can poke and prod at it.
And this can let you
just be more productive
when you're like making all these changes.
Also, you can run your model
for debuggers and profilers
and add all sorts of analysis tools
to them, to just really understand
how they are doing what they are doing.
And finally, if we don't force you
to represent your computation
in a separate way than the host
programming language you are using,
you can just use all
the machinery of your host programming
language to do control flow and data flow,
and complicated data structures,
which for some models is key to being
able to make your model working at all.
So, I hope you're not wondering,
"How do I get to use this?"
And the way you use this is super easy.
You import TensorFlow
and you call
tf.enable_eager_execution
And once you do that,
what happens is anytime you run
a TensorFlow operation,
like in this case a .matmul,
instead of TensorFlow building a graph
that later when executed is going
to run that matrix multiplication,
we just immediately run
that matrix multiplication for you
and give you the result.
And you can print it,
you can slice it, you can dice it,
you can do whatever you want with it.
And because things
are happening immediately,
you can have highly dynamic control flow
that depends on the actual values
of the computation you're executing.
And here is just a simple
Wolfe conditions line search
example that I wrote.
And it doesn't matter, it just matters;
it has like while loops
that depend on complicated values
that are computer-based
on the computation.
And this runs just fine
on whatever device you have.
And together with this
enable_eager_execution thing,
we're also bringing you
a few symbols in TensorFlow
that make it easier for you
to write code that's going to work,
both when building graphs
and when we're executing eagerly.
And we're also bringing you
a new way of doing gradients,
because I'm sure you're familiar now
with how we do gradients
in normal TensorFlow.
Where you just create your variable,
you create your loss function,
and I hope you can think of a better
loss function than this one.
And then you call tf.gradients
to differentiate it.
But when you have eager execution, we try
to be as efficient as we possibly can
And if you're going to...
one thing to think about is
that if you're going to differentiate
a computation,
you need to keep track
in memory of information
about what happened so far,
like your activations
and things like that.
But I don't want you to pay
for the cost of this tracking
when you're not computing gradients
because performance is really
like the whole reason why we're doing this
is because we want to use these big,
nice pieces of hardware
that train models super fast.
So, when eager execution is enabled,
when you want to compute gradients,
and you use this little context manager
to keep a tape active,
and the tape just records
all the operations you execute,
so we can play it back
when you've computed the gradients.
Otherwise, the API is the same.
Also, writing training loops in eager,
as Derrick pointed out,
is much...
is very easy and straightforward.
You can just use a Python for loop
to iterate over your data sets
and data sets work in eager just fine.
And they work with the same high
performance you get
in the graph execution engine.
Then you can just do your predictions,
compute your gradients,
supply your gradients
and do all the things
you're used to doing.
But really the interesting thing
about eager execution
is not when you're just writing
this code as finished,
that is done,
that we already know works,
but when you're still developing,
when you want to do things like debug.
So...
when eager execution is enabled,
you can just take any model code--
and I used my simple,
silly gradient example here--
add notes to like drop into the Python
debugger anywhere you want.
And once you're in the Python debugger,
you have the full power
of debugging available.
You can print the value of any tensor,
you can change the value of any tensor.
You can run any operation
you want on any tensor.
And this will hopefully empower you
to really understand
what's going on in your models
and really be able to fix
any problems you have.
You can also take eager execution
code and profile it,
using whatever profiling tool you are most
familiar and comfortable with.
So, here I have a little [inaudible] model
that just does a .matmul
and a bias_add.
And let's pretend I don't know
which of these operations
is going to be the bottleneck.
Which one is lower?
And I'm sure you all know the answer
that the matmul is a lot more expensive.
But here you can just run your code
through your Python profiler
like you would do with any
other programming job,
and find out that the matmul
is like 15 times more expensive
for my batch size here
than my bias addition.
And also,
by the way those examples are run
on the Google collaboratory thing,
which is this...
completely public-shared,
GPU-capable interface
for Jupiter notebooks
that are like hosted on Google Cloud.
It's pretty cool and I think
we have a demo on eager
that's hosted on that.
And you can play out with later,
or if you're on livestream,
you can play out of it now
if you can find the link.
But together with eager,
we're bringing you a lot of new APIs
that make it easier for you
to build TensorFlow graphs
and to execute models.
And these APIs are compatible
with both eager execution
and graph building.
So one that's been
a recurring low priority feature request
is how to customize gradients
in TensorFlow.
And I'm sure you are familiar with a few
of the tricks that people have,
like stop gradients and functions
and things like that.
But we're introducing a new API that works
in both eager and graph execution
And what I like about this example is that
it's a thing that's been asked by many,
many people, how to do it.
If I want to run my forward pass
and then in the backward pass,
take the gradient of a particular tensor
and clip it, clip it's norm to keep it
small to prevent it from exploding.
And it just takes six lines of code
to make a version of tf.identity
that in the backward pass
clips its gradient,
and I think this is really cool.
And I look forward to seeing
what you guys can do with this
when you're doing
more than six lines of code
and solving all sorts of new,
interesting research problems.
A big, big change when programming
with eager from graph
that I really want you to stop
and think about
is that we're trying
to make everything as pythonic
and object-oriented as possible.
So, variables in TensorFlow are...
usually are a complicated thing
to think about.
But when eager execution is enabled,
it's much simpler.
A TensorFlow variable
is just a Python object.
You create one, you have it.
You can write, you can change its value,
you can read its value.
When the last reference to it goes away,
you get your memory back,
even if it's your GPU memory.
So, if you want to share variables,
you just reuse those objects.
You don't worry about variable scopes
or any other complicated structure.
And because we have this
object-oriented approach to variables,
we can look at some
of the APIs in TensorFlow
and like rethink them in a way
that's a little more object-oriented
and easier to use.
And a very...
one that really stood out to us
as needing an overhaul
was the metrics API.
So, we're introducing
this new tfe.metrics package,
where each metric has two methods,
one that updates the value
and one that gives you the result.
And hopefully, this is an API that everyone
is going to find familiar to use
and please don't try to compare
this with the other metrics API.
(laughs)
We're also giving you a way to do
object-oriented saving
of TensorFlow models.
If you've tried looking
at TensorFlow checkpoints now,
you know that they depend
on variable names.
And variable names depend not just
on the name you gave to a variable,
but on all other variables
which are present in your graph.
This can make it a little hard for you
to save and load subsets of your model
and really control
what's in your checkpoint.
So we're introducing
a completely object-oriented
Python object-based saving API,
where you...
it's like Python pickle,
like any variable that's reachable
from your model gets saved
and your model gets saved.
You can save any subset of your model.
You can load any subset of your model.
You can even use this tfe.checkpoint
object to build things you want to save
that have more than a model.
And here we have an optimizer
and a global_step
but really you can put
whatever you want in there.
And the idea is that this object graph
that eventually goes down to variables
is something you can save and load.
So you can have your [GAN]
and save and load your discriminators
and your generators
separate from each other.
Then you can take your discriminator
and load it backup
as like another newer network that you
can use in another part of a model.
And this should give you a lot more
control to get a lot more out
of TensorFlow checkpointing.
But the real question that everybody
asks me when I tell them
that I work on eager execution
is, Is it fast?
Because graphs...
have this high performance promise.
So, how fast can it make this thing
that runs Python code all the time?
And the answer is
that we can make it fast enough.
For models that are highly
computationally intensive,
you pretty much don't see
any Python overhead,
and we're as fast as graph TensorFlow.
For...
sometimes slightly faster,
in reasons that I don't fully understand,
even for highly dynamic models,
you have comparative performance
with anything else you can find.
And please don't get attached
to these numbers.
We have many more benchmarks
in our codebase.
And we're optimizing eager
performance very aggressively,
but I hope that the message you'll get
out of this is that if your model
can keep a GPU busy,
if you're doing large convolusions,
large matrix multiplications,
there is almost no cost in experimenting
and doing your research and model building
with eager execution turned on.
But when you're doing smaller things,
there are some overheads
and I want to go over them.
But again don't get attached to them
because we're being very aggressive
about optimizing this.
If you just run a no op in TensorFlow,
like an identity,
it takes almost a microsecond
to execute it.
If you run that with eager
execution turned on,
there's an extra microsecond of overhead.
If you're tracing gradients,
there are another 3 microseconds
of overhead that you get.
But if you're just enqueuing
something on the GPU stream,
that alone takes like
single-digit microsecond.
So, if you can execute enough
computation to keep a GPU busy,
you're unlikely to see anything bad
from using eager execution,
and again these numbers
are improving very quickly.
Please don't get too attached to them.
But there is this large ecosystem
of TensorFlow code libraries,
models, frameworks, checkpoints
that I don't think anyone
wants to give up.
And I don't want you to give up
if you want to use eager execution.
So, we're also thinking really hard
about how you can interoperate
between eager and graph.
One way is to like call
into graphs from eager code.
And you can do that with tfe.make_template
which has this create
graph function argument
when you pass through
to it with build a graph,
for that little Python function
that you wrote.
And then you can use it an manipulate
and call the graph from eager execution.
We also have the reverse,
which is how to call
into eager from a graph.
Let's say you have a big graph
that you understand everything in it,
but there's a little chunk
of your computation
that you really don't know how to express.
And either you don't know,
or you don't want to bother expressing it,
in using like TensorFlow graphs.
So you can wrap it in a tfe.py_func
and what you get in there
when the Python function is executing
are eager tensors, that you can
run any TensorFlow op in,
including convolutions and other things
that are not available in my_py.
But you can also look at the values
and inspect and use dynamic
control flow in there.
So, I hope with these two things together,
you can really reuse eager
and graph code across.
But really the easiest way
to get eager and graph compatibility
is to just write model code
that's going to work in both ways.
And if you think about it,
once your model is fully written,
debugged and [tested],
there's not much there that tells you
whether you need to build a graph
or to execute eagerly.
So write, iterate, debug in eager
and then import that same code
into a graph,
put it in Estimator,
deploy it on a TPU pod,
deploy it on a GPU,
distribute it and do whatever you want.
And like this is what we've done
in our example models
and there's going to be a link
in the end of the presentation,
so you don't need to like worry
about writing this down.
So, here is some practical advice for you.
Write code that's going to work well
when executing eagerly
and when building graphs.
And to do that, use
the Keras layers. They're great.
They're object-oriented;
they're pythonic.
They're easy to understand,
manipulate and play around with.
Use the Keras model
to stitch those layers together,
that will guide you in saving and loading
and training and all sorts of things
automatically if you want,
but you're not forced to use those.
Use tf.contrib.summary
instead of tf.summary.
They will move to the tensor board
open source package very soon.
So, if you're watching this on video,
it probably already happened.
Use the tfe.metrics
instead of the tf.metrics,
because these are object-oriented,
friendlier to use,
and friendlier in eager.
And use the object-based saving,
which is a much nicer
user experience anyway.
So, I hope you're going to want
to do this all the time.
If you do all of this,
it's highly likely your code
is going to work super well
in both eager execution
and graph building.
So now, I'd like to take some time
to tell you why you should
enable eager execution.
You know like a real good...
important reason for us that led us
to build this in the first place
is that if you're new to machine learning,
or you're new to TensorFlow
and you want to learn,
being able to play with these objects
and manipulate them directly
is just a much nicer experience
than having to build a graph
and interact with later in a session.
It's a lot more intuitive,
lets you understand
what's going on much better.
So I've shown you, just by all means
go straight into your execution,
play around with it
and figure out how to get graphs later.
Also, if you're a researcher
and you're quickly iterating over models.
You're changing their internal
properties and...
you're comparing them and you're
trying to do models that are non trivial
that we in the TensorFlow team
were not thinking about
when we designed TensorFlow.
Eager execution will make it much easier
for you to understand what's going on,
to debug what's going on,
to be productive in advance.
So, if you're a researcher
this is for you.
Also, if your model's not working
and you want to understand why,
being able to enable eager execution
and then [start through] it in a debugger,
change some values, play around with it.
Understand that is priceless,
and that has saved me a lot of time.
Similarly, if you want to profile
a model using like the full power
of whatever tool you like
to use to profile Python,
eager execution is your friend.
Also, there are some models
like recursive RNN's
that are just much easier to express
if you don't need to put
your entire computation
in a static data flow graph.
If you're working on one of those models,
eager execution is also a choice for you.
But really the reason
I think you should enable this
is that it's fun.
It's a very nice and intuitive way
of interacting with TensorFlow,
and I hope you're going to have
a lot of fun experimenting with it.
So now, I would like
to point to a few things.
Some of my colleagues,
sitting over there now,
they're going to be in the demo
room during the break
with laptops, with [collabs]
that are like Jupiter notebooks
to let you type and try
eager mode there.
Please go give it a try.
Or if you're watching this
on the livestream,
type that short link--
hopefully it will stay on the screen
long enough for you to type it--
and play with it right now.
It's really nice.
We have a Getting Started
Guide on TensorFlow
that should be live now.
programmers_guide/eager
that tells you what you need
to know about eager execution
and what you need to know
about starting to use TensorFlow
using eager execution.
We also have a ton of example models,
like from RNNs to [inaudible]
to all sorts of things,
that are available behind that link.
And I encourage you
to look at them and see
how it's easy to write the model
and how easy it is to also reuse
the same code from graphs
for deployment.
We have deployment
for graphs for all models
except for the highly dynamic ones
that are just really hard
to write in a graph form.
And give it a try.
If you give it a try,
let us know how it went.
We're super excited
to share this with you.
I hope you're going to have
a great time playing with this.
And, yes.
Thank you.
(clapping)
♪ (music) ♪